next up will be my you wonder bunny on
the orient buffers thank you okay so
this is the reordering buffer management
problem we have an input stream of balls
of various colors and we have a buffer
that has some fixed capacity K and in
this example k equals three the balls as
they arrive enter the buffer and then of
course at some point the buffer becomes
full and in order to be able to process
the next input item you have to remove
one of the balls that are currently in
the buffer and the order by which they
enter the buffer does not matter so so
you can choose any one of these three
balls to remove now for instance of the
green ball and then the new input item
enters the buffer and now you have to
remove some other ball and and you keep
doing this until the entire input
sequence is exhausted and then you just
have to clear the buffer so so the final
steps are just clearing the buffer of
all the remaining balls so this is how
you produce out the output so the output
is some permutation of the input but
it's not an arbitrary permutations
it's a permutation that can be realized
by a buffer of size K now so so that's
the input in the up output what is the
objective the objective is to minimize
the context switching cost of the output
sequence and in this specific case that
we will talk about for most of the talk
the context switching cost is simply 1
whenever we change colors so so this
particular
solution costs five because there are
five color blocks in the output this
isn't the optimal solution the optimal
solution in this case is four and our
mistake was actually the removing the
green ball as our first move if we would
have delayed that we would have had only
four color batches so here's a list of
excuses why to study this problem
they're not that interesting for us
right now for me perhaps the last one is
the most interesting so I think this
problem reveals some fascinating facets
of online computing and therefore it's
an appealing model to study
and of course you can produce slides
with colorful and joyful photos okay so
so in the next two slides I'm going to
summarize everything that's known about
this problem right now hopefully first
of all in the offline setting so so so
we know the entire input sequence in
advance and we want to compute an
optimal scheduling of removing stuff
from the buffer the problem is known to
be np-hard there are at least two proofs
of that and at least one of them is also
correct most likely and there is a
constant factor approximation the
initial constant by victor wobbly and
myself was I think something a little
bit less than 135 and that was improved
more to 6 or so about half of that 60
something so so that's the best constant
that's currently known in the online
setting so there are no hardness result
I mean it's not known to be a px hard or
anything like that in the online setting
in fact things are much better due to a
lot of work by many people including
Anna who is right here with us so so
there is a deterministic upper bound of
square root of walk a competitive ratio
and that's nearly matched by a
deterministic lower bound of square root
of law K over log ok so there's a small
gap there in the randomized case the
bounds are asymptotically tight so other
than the leading constant we know
everything there is an order log log K
randomized algorithm and that's matched
by previously known Omega lock lock a
lower bound on the competitive ratio
I'm sorry K is the size of the buffer K
is the size of the buffer now we talked
about this very simple uniform context
switching cost we're changing to a
different color just costs one whenever
whenever it's done in the output there
are more sophisticated context switching
cost models so perhaps the next simplest
one is the case of non-uniform costs in
non-uniform costs each color has a
different cost so if I switch to green
I'll pay something if I switch to blue
I'll pay something else and there the
picture is somewhat work here so almost
all the results include a term that
depends on the maximum ratio of the
costs and of course the maximum ratio of
the cost could be arbitrarily large in
this model so so it it need not give us
anything that depends only on K so here
is what's known there is an
approximation algorithm triple log of
this gamma times K there is a square
root of log gamma ke upper bound on the
deterministic competitive ratio the only
bound that does not depend on this gamma
is this bound order law K over log log K
so so that's the only thing that we know
that doesn't depend on the on the
weights themselves and there's also a
log log gamma K squared randomized
algorithm that's no it doesn't really
matter right it's just a factor of two
so so so you could so the star metric is
not exactly identical to the non-uniform
cost model because in the non uniform
cost
you're only paying the weight of the
color you're switching to but you can
define a star where you know each of the
colors has half the weight of their
actual weight and then you're paying for
moving into the color and for moving out
of the color each one is you pay half so
that's the same up to an additive term
now they're more general cost function
so you can induce say a metric on the
colors and and then even less is known I
mean there's been a lot of work on this
or some work on this and some progress
but you see the I won't go over the
results I'm afraid I might not have
enough time the one thing to know one
important and very simple fact to know
is that if you do not change the input
sequence at all so you just output the
input sequence you don't actually need
the buffer for that right you need a
buffer of size one you're not even using
the buffer except for one position the
input sequence is no worse than two K
minus one times the optimal solution so
there is a bound here on how bad you can
do and it's about in terms of K alone
whereas all of these results do not
depend just on K so so we don't know if
the if there's something better than
linear in K which depends only on K
there are other models
there's the block devices model which is
a slight variation of this in in fact
this result of a domotic at all one of
the ingredients of what I'll show you
here borrows heavily from that paper
it's it's a variation where when you
remove a color you only remove the stuff
that's currently in the buffer and you
can't append to it new items of the same
color that are
arriving while we were removing it so
that's the difference it makes a rather
significant difference in in what what
you in how you need to solve the problem
but the work on that actually is useful
also for the reordering buffer problem C
C is the set of colors sorry I didn't
mention that C is just a set of colors
so it's K no it's not k K is the size of
the buffer okay so I want to talk about
linear programming relaxations because
we're supposed to be all about
continuous optimization here so here is
a linear programming relaxation for the
uniform reordering buffer problem and if
it's non-uniform you just have to plug
in the weights here so it just changes
the objective function so what does the
LP represent X IJ in the integer version
of this is an indicator variable that
says that item I is removed at outputs
law J so so so the output sequence the
input sequence starts its law one and
goes all the way to slot N and the
output sequence starts at slot K plus 1
because the first K steps are just the
initial K items entering the buffer and
it ends it slot K plus n so and X IJ is
the in is is the indicator or in the in
the LP solution it's the fraction of
item I that is removed it it outputs
logic and then we have two obvious sets
of constraints so every item has to be
removed at some point so so this is the
first set of constraints and the second
set of constraints is that at every time
step we cannot remove more than one item
so these are two obvious constraints
this is a somewhat less obvious concet
of constraints this set of constraints
is necessary in order to be
able to express the objective function
in terms of these X I J's and
intuitively what the set of constraints
does we will soon get rid of it but and
have a different representation but what
the set of constraint says is that if
you remove an item I stepped J where the
next item of the set of the same color
is already available then you're also
going to remove that next item so it's
also this constraint doesn't allow you
to cut sequences of the same color if
they can be continued and of course an
optimal solution would have that
property there's no reason to change the
context if you can continue with the
same color so this is a pictorial view
of how the fractional solution looks
like or at least one way that you can
express it you can think of it as as I'm
sorry yeah yes
but it will become even more obvious now
so that that's why I'm not going into it
so so the way to think about the
fractional solution as is as follows
think of here's the time line and and
you know our schedule starts at time k
plus 1 and ends at time k plus and so so
these are I mean it looks continuous but
what I mean is a discrete time line and
we have these what we call batches so a
batch IJ or a blue batch IJ is just a
sequence I of consecutive blue items
consecutive in the input sequence that
are removed starting from slot J so so J
indicates the initial time slot where
these are removed and the LP just
computes a fractional packing of of
these batches so each batch here has a
height I mean the total height is one
because in every time unit one item is
removed and each batch has a height
corresponding to its weight in the
packing an integer solution is just a
packing of integral batches instead of
fractional batches so this how this is
how an integer solution would look like
and this leads us to the following
equivalent formulation so here instead
of the X I J's we will have X capital IJ
variables and X capital IJ simply
indicates that the weight at which the
batch IJ is packed in the packing so so
so now the objective function is clear
right because we're just summing the
total weight of all the batches that
were scheduling and the constraints are
also obvious every item has to be
removed at least once so the sum of
weights of all the batches that contain
a certain item has to be at least one
and in every timeslot if I look at all
the batches that use that timeslot their
total weight has to be at most one
and of course because of the indexing
both of these in in in any feasible
solution will be equations and not
inequalities it's it's a sequence of
consecutive items of the same color that
are removed starting at in slot 2 J so I
indicates the sequence and J indicates
the starting output slot for that
sequence there's only a polynomial
number of them right because they're
consecutive so so so they have a
starting point and an end point and that
determines the whole sequence it's not a
subset a range is over starting and
finish positions of the items in the
bench so this is the dual program the
dual program is also pretty simple we
have variables Y I for all the input
positions and variables ZJ for all the
output the positions and I'm missing
something there might be boards that are
not consecutive of the same column that
are not consecutive in the input that
you might still be able to put the
negative in the output yes by
consecutive I mean when you look at this
particular color they there's no missing
ball in there in that range that's what
I meant by consecutive not not that they
come one after the other there could be
other balls of other colors in the
middle yeah exactly yes
so the constraints here that if I look
at the if I look at any batch I sum the
Y eyes over all the items there and I
sum the Z J's over all the positions
where these items are removed by this
particular batch this has to be bounded
by one okay
so so so let's do some things with the
selfie I mean we have an LP so it could
be good it could be bad here is one very
simple thing we can do with it
let's consider the following so so this
is now the offline world for now let's
consider the following rounding
procedure so so I'm doing the rounding
by going over the time index so I'm
looking at the first time index where
nothing is being removed and I have to
fill that up so I'm going I'll look at
my buffer if there exists in the buffer
an item that has LP weight at most half
so that means that the LP removed this
item with weight at least a half I'm
going to evict this entire color from
the buffer and of course everything that
can be appended to that while we're
removing it and otherwise we just keep
accumulating items in the buffer no it's
it's one item but but the item
determines an entire sequence of items
that will be removed if there is one
specific item that has weight less than
a half I will remove the entire color
okay now of course the cost of my
solution increases by a factor of at
most two I mean this requires some proof
but but you can show that and on the
other hand what's the size of the buffer
that I need to store all all the items
because sometimes I have no item that
has weights less than a half than the LP
so the point is that at every point in
time every item in the buff in my buffer
has weight at least half in the LP and
since the LP constrains indirectly the
capacity of the buffer to be K I can
accommodate all these items with
for a size-two cake yes I knew you would
ask that it constrains it indirectly by
setting the first time slot where an
item is removed to be k plus 1 that's
where the buffer capacity is determined
because III have to remove all of these
items and I have exactly n positions to
remove them so I must remove one item in
every position and that maintains the
capacity of the buffer so so so I can
accommodate all of this with a buffer of
size 2 K so so in fact if I really want
to solve the ka buffer I need to solve
the LP for a buffer of size K over 2 and
then do this rounding now what do I pay
for that well if if I'm solving the LP
for a smaller buffer I might get a cost
which is much higher than the optimal
cost for a buffer of size K but there is
a result of anglers in westerman the
chose that if it's not for a factor of 2
it's for a factor of 4 it shows that the
optimal solution for a buffer of size K
is at most order of law K times the
optimal solution for a but for a buffer
that is 4 times as large so that's also
true for a buffer that's at least that
that's twice as large right that's a
smaller buffer so I'm not and and this
law K is tight for for the factor 4 we
don't really know the truth for factor 2
so so in fact this thing gives you a log
ke approximation algorithm and also la
ke and gravity gap for the LP now there
are much better results the the
integrality gap and and and there's a
constant approximation algorithm and
into gravity gap it's not we don't know
that for non uniform costs but for
uniform costs that's known
I don't think I'll have time to show
that but let's see so so let's talk a
little bit about online algorithms so
here is a very simple online algorithm I
hope I hope I'll be able to show a
little bit more than this so so think of
it as follows
every item has a penalty counter and I
look at all the items in my buffer and
so the items just accumulate these
penalties until they are evicted from
the buffer so I take all the items in my
buffer and I raise their penalties
uniformly and continuously of course you
need to discretize that in order to get
an actual algorithm now as soon as I
have a color in my buffer that has total
penalty equal to one I vicked the color
from the buffer so that includes all the
items that accumulated this penalty of
one and possibly additional items that
will enter the buffer as I'm removing
those items so so this very simple
algorithm is can be shown to be law K
over log log K competitive even for
non-uniform cost so for non-uniform
costs the penalty has to reach the cost
of the color not one and the proof is in
fact uses the LP it uses the LP of
course the algorithm doesn't use the the
LP but the proof uses the LP by
constructing a dual solution that bounds
the cost of the algorithm and the dual
solution is very simple the proof that
this is a feasible solution is the part
that's non-trivial in this result so
here is the dual solution ZJ the Z J's
remember the these correspond to output
slots they just grow monotonically and
ZJ indicates the total penalty
accumulated per item up to up to slaw
gesso so this is sort of a global
counter of this continuous process that
we're doing and why I is set when I is
removed it's set to it's set in a way
that why I minus Z of the slot where I
is removed is equal to the total penalty
that I accumulated divided by the
approximation factor and this is a
feasel so so the the hard part here is
to prove that this is a feasible
solution once you have this as a
feasible solution you know that then you
get the approximation guarantee another
thing that you can show and this is
somewhat important is is the following
thing that this algorithm again by dual
fitting is not if if if all the color
blocks are large the algorithm performs
very well so so if if all the removed
color blocks are large if they all have
size at least
s the algorithm will be order log K over
s competitive and this might not
necessarily be tight for all s is a
parameter of the output so if you happen
to be lucky and this is what happened
then you know that your algorithm
performed well
okay how much time do I have
okay let me do this very quickly so I
won't go over any of these details so so
sort of ever since Nev annsofi
did a lot of work on online algorithms
the obvious tool to use is the
primal-dual schema and in fact Anna and
her co-authors did just that for the
block devices problem and here we're
borrowing rather heavily from that so so
I just wanted to point out there are two
major problems in applying the
primal-dual schema to this formulation
the first problem is that the primal has
both covering and packing constraints so
normally the primal-dual schema applies
when you have a covering problem or when
you have a pure packing problem and here
they're mixed and what happens when
they're mixed is that the dual has
negative signs and and and that's an
annoying thing for the primal-dual
schema because it causes problems so it
turns out that you can do things the
other problem is that when you raise a
primal variable it doesn't determine a
decision just for the current time slot
but it determines decisions for future
time slots because you're scheduling a
batch you're not scheduling an
individual item and that also causes
various problems
I won't I don't have time to go over
this but let me just explain one little
thing here so the solution to all of our
problems is the following so first of
all we're going to raise some of the why
I and some of the Z J's variable
yes Lee so we're raising both the Y's
and the Z J's we're raising all the Y's
that are still not fully scheduled so
that includes all the ones that are in
the buffer and all the future ones and
we're raising all the ZJ starting from
the current position now the dual
increase rate is going to be the number
of items that are still present in the
buffer minus the capacity of the buffer
and this is a problem because the number
of items in the buffer could be exactly
the capacity of the buffer right so that
could be zero and that's bad because
we're not gaining anything in the dual
the solution to this is a resource
augmentation algorithm sorry is a
resource augmentation argument where you
actually compete against the dual that
is using a slightly smaller buffer so
you're you're you're using a buffer of
size K minus K over log K instead of K
and this gives you some slack here and
this slack is good enough if the batches
that you're removing are small R at most
K over log K okay so we have an
algorithm that's good if all the batches
are big if all the batches are at least
K over log a we get log log K if all the
batches are below K over log K we this
argument leads also to a log low K so we
need to combine these two things and
that's actually the biggest difficulty
here how to combine these two arguments
into one and I won't explain that just
what what is the essence of the problem
here when you start accumulating a color
in the buffer you have no idea if it's
going to be big or small when you will
remove it so you need some mechanism
that will that will decide if it's going
to be big or small and of course you
can't just guess because then your guest
might be wrong and the whole R and the
whole algorithm won't work so so there
is some complicated mechanism
that needs to be used freezing some of
the items and waiting to see if they
accumulate and then releasing them all
this is a big mess so I won't go into
this just to conclude here are some open
problems so the non-uniform case is
almost completely resolved you know
except for this deterministic gap small
gap that seems pretty hard to close but
[Music]
some one in one remaining question is
the approximability of the problem so
can we find an approximation algorithm
that has a small constant not something
like 60 something and a pts is not
excluded by anything that we know so
this problem might as well have a pas
then in the non-uniform costs case my
[Music]
belief is that these should be the same
bounds is in the uniform case but right
now this seems pretty hard the problem
there is is that all the strong
arguments charge certain colors on other
colors and if they don't have the same
weights this charging is a difficult
thing it involves packing you know
charging many small many low weight
colors on one big weight color or some
and that's hard to do so so that's the
the difficulty there and then in general
metrics of course any little o of K
guarantee is interesting both online and
offline so we don't know any
approximation algorithm better than the
online algorithms for general metrics
any LP relaxation for the problem it's
it seems like a challenging thing to
come up with or you know STP relaxation
or whatever interesting tool can be
developed and there are no
summation algorithms they're not derived
from the online algorithms so that's it
so you had this one point that you
didn't talk about the extra memory is it
consistent with would it be contradict
anything we know so far to say that a
constant factor extra buffers and a
constant there is the slower bound right
I actually mentioned it if you if the
smaller buffer is K over 4 you have to
pay a logarithmic factor for that so
there are sequences where the smaller
buffer will cost log K times the bigger
buff oh no nothing nothing will not in
fact there might even be such results I
didn't mention the results that that
actually compared buffers of different
sizes yeah so there's nothing that would
in fact that's how one of the earlier
results works it gives a constant factor
competitive ratio against takes a buffer
that is 1/4 the the buffer that you want
okay I didn't understand the question
[Applause]
final Speaker of the day will be you
who's at Simons